[Music]
foreign
VP of cloud AI industry Solutions and
I'm sudhir husband I'm senior director
of product management for data analytics
at Google Cloud the last few years have
led us to a Tipping Point with AI
adoption where we have seen the impact
of AI across more and more organizations
and more and more use cases
organizations for many Industries and
varying level of ml expertise are
solving business critical problems with
AI from creating compelling customer
experience to optimizing operations to
automating routine tasks these
organizations learn to innovate faster
and ultimately get ahead in the
marketplace
but how do they get there first
challenge start with data it is the
challenge to manage this growth and
complexity it is a challenge to prepare
data for AI and ml usage
second AI expertise is scarce how many
AI experts do you need to get your first
model into production what about the
next set of use cases
and finally if you have all the pieces
in place the road from prototype to
production can still take months if not
years
how can you scale faster with confidence
I'm proud to announce the general
availability of big lake to help you
break the data silos and unify your data
lakes and warehouses Big Lake will also
support Apache Iceberg which is becoming
the standard for open source table
formats for your data leaks and soon we
will also add support for other formats
like Delta Lake and hoodie our built-in
support for Apache spark in bigquery
will allow data practitioners to create
bigquery stored procedures unifying
their work in spark with their SQL
Pipelines
today we are announcing support for
unstructured data in bigquery through
object tables object tables enable you
to take advantage of common security and
governance across your data you can now
build data products that unify
structured and unstructured data in
bigquery
this makes bigquery One-Stop solution to
store manage and process all types of
data at global scale Google Cloud
addresses this challenge head on by
offering a wide range of capabilities
that can increase the reach of AIML to
more users and help your scarce resource
your data scientists to achieve greater
productivity for some workloads faster
is what it's all about
I am excited to introduce vertex AI
Vision a revolutionary end-to-end
computer vision application development
service
that helps you to be able to reduce the
amount of time it takes to build
computer vision application from days to
minutes at a fraction of the cost was it
easy to use drag and drop interface and
pre-trained model for common tasks
vertex AI vision is the One-Stop shop to
build deploy manage computer vision
application
we hope you have enjoyed the session
thank you so much for attending
[Music]